[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui serait le successeur de Jean 23 les
80 cardinaux venus du monde entier à les
lire dans le secret du concla
parmi eux le cardinal mantini archevêque
de Milan bien connu souvent cité son nom
n'était qu'une silhouette au milieu dos
et avec la parade traditionnelle les
rites de la clôture se déroulaient après
l'extra homeless qui fait des membres du
Sacré Collège autant de prisonniers
dehors sur l'immense place Saint-Pierre
la foule allait attendre caméra braquet
téléphone très à transmettre les
nouvelles au monde entier l'apparition
de la fumée noire si l'élection n'était
pas faite blanche si le pape était élu
deux fois elle fut noir la troisième
était blanche
[Musique]
et voici qu'au balcon de Saint-Pierre
apparaissaient le cardinal Octavia ni
qui allait annoncer le nom du nouveau
pas
[Applaudissements]
sur l'ouverture de la loggia se dessine
une mince forme blanche que la foule
remet à clams Jean-Baptiste Montigny est
maintenant le pape Paul VI
262E successeur de Saint-Pierre
[Musique]
l'anniversaire du 18 juin devant le
mémorial de la France combattante au
Mont Valérien a revêtu la simplicité et
le recueillement désormais traditionnels
le général de Gaulle est venu comme
chaque année au milieu de ceux qui
furent ces compagnons ranimer la flamme
qui brûle devant la crypte ou 16
résistants sont ensevelies 23 ans
aujourd'hui depuis l'appel du général de
Gaulle alors si inconnu si solitaire
mais qui donc a oublié
[Musique]
étape d'un voyage de 10 jours au cours
desquels il passera par l'Allemagne
l'Irlande l'Angleterre et l'Italie le
président Kennedy a été accueilli à
Cologne par le chancelier à de Noé
[Musique]
c'est comme on l'a dit un voyage dont la
signification politique est pratiquement
pas moins de riz du fait que le
chancelier de Noël va laisser la place à
Monsieur Érard que Monsieur Mac Millan
est pour ainsi dire condamné et que le
gouvernement italien est un gouvernement
de transition
[Musique]
le sens de ce voyage n'est pas très
profond l'accueil de l'Allemagne au
président des États-Unis n'en a pas
moins été très chaleureux c'est au
milieu d'une foule que la police avait
peine à contenir que le président
Kennedy a gagné le cœur de Cologne pour
l'Allemagne de l'Ouest c'est un effet
une nouvelle garantie de sa sécurité que
vient affirmer la visite de Kennedy
le retour à Moscou des deux cosmonautes
du vol de Vostok 5 et Vostok 6 a été
plus encore peut-être que les précédents
l'occasion d'un triomphe à l'aéroport
d'abord où Valentina terescova et
Valérie Bukowski ont été accueillis
affectueusement par Monsieur Kochav et
les plus hautes personnalités
soviétiques
au milieu d'une foule considérable les
deux héros du cosmos entourant monsieur
coachoff ont ensuite gagné la place
Rouge ou la population moscovite s'était
rassemblée en grand nombre
[Musique]
de la tribune d'honneur monsieur
proutchoff au milieu d'un délire de
ration présenta les deux cosmonautes
bicovski qui a battu tous les records de
durée dans le cosmos avec 82 révolutions
en 5 jours moins 6 minutes Valentina
terescova la première femme de l'espace
[Musique]
dans chaque cité on a créé des
installations souvent considérables pour
assurer la purification et le contrôle
de l'eau c'est qu'elle mette à l'abri
des maladies épidémiques des dizaines
des centaines de milliers de
consommateurs quotidiens
et spécialistes ont même la charge d'un
apprécier le goût ce qui n'empêche pas
les citadins de faire quand même la fine
bouche mais c'est tout et saine même si
sa saveur est discutable
[Musique]
rien après cela l'heure des vacances le
citadin qui a loué une charmante maison
dans un charmant village ne peut
résister au romantisme du Puy ou dors
une eau si clair si fraîche si naturelle
du moins le croit-il faute d'avoir fait
la relation entre le spectacle du
voisinage et l'effet des infiltrations
dans le sol et c'est ainsi qu'on
constate toujours après les vacances une
recrudescence de tifoïde car rien n'est
plus trompeur qu'une eau fraîche et
limpide il suffit de la regarder au
microscope
dans un village sans adduction d'eau
remettez vous en donc à l'appareil
purificateur à ozone
mais si vous êtes campeur et tenté par
l'eau d'une source qui chante au creux
des rochers il n'est bien sûr pas
question d'apporter toute une
installation de purification
voici alors une recette dont
l'application est des plus simples
quelques gouttes d'eau de javel dans 10
litres d'eau
agité avec un simple bâton de bois
conservé soigneusement propre
laissez reposer une demi-heure pour que
le chlore et le temps d'agir vous pouvez
boire alors avec tranquillité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
amateur de vieilles fermes de bois et de
ruisseaux dites-vous que les charmes de
la nature ne sont que ce qu'ils sont ne
gâchez pas vos vacances par un accès de
romantisme inconsidéré la civilisation
de l'eau de javel a du bon
[Musique]
il y a 30 ans grâce à Jean Mermoz la
route de l'Atlantique Sud était ouverte
à bord de l'arc-en-ciel Mermoz réalisait
dans les deux sens la liaison aérienne
entre l'Afrique et l'Amérique du Sud
mais c'était plus qu'un exploit sportif
qu'il avait réalisé il inaugurait la
ligne commerciale qui de Toulouse par
Casablanca Dakar natal et Buenos Aires
menait jusqu'à Santiago du Chili
30 ans après cette aventure triomphale
de l'Aéropostale ce n'est pas sans
émotion qu'on peut retrouver aujourd'hui
dans les sables du désert mauritanien
près de porétienne les restes du hangar
qui servit à Mermoz retrouvé aussi le
Guide mort qui servit d'interprète à
l'aviateur dans ses contacts avec les
hommes bleus
trouver encore non loin du hangar le
poste rudimentaire ou Mermoz et ses
compagnons s'enfermaient pour passer la
nuit à l'abri des coups de main
mais autour de ses souvenirs que de
changement des villes viennent de
pousser dans le désert kansado au bord
de la mer Zouerat dans la région de
fort-bouraud au pied de la montagne de
fer c'est d'ailleurs se faire qui a tout
transformé se faire de la Kédia djill
qui affole les boussoles des équipiers
de Mermoz
un important complexe minier assure
maintenant l'exploitation à ciel ouvert
du minerai qui avec 66% de teneurs et
l'un des plus purs du monde
[Musique]
le président de la République Islamique
de Mauritanie et Monsieur Triboulet
ministre de la Coopération ont inauguré
la mise en service de ces gigantesques
mines dont on évalue les réserves à 200
millions de tonnes ils ont assisté au
chargement du train de 135 wagons
capable de transporter en un seul voyage
dix mille tonnes de minerais jusqu'à la
mer distance de 650 km
trois ans plus tôt il n'y avait rien ici
que le sable arrive aussi l'événement
a-t-il pris une allure de fête autour
d'un échoui gigantesque de 320 moutons
et dans l'allégresse générale les hommes
du désert firent tonnèrent aux
traditionnels festins tout morceaux de
mouton fut de bonnes prises
[Musique]
le train de minerai cependant achevêt à
kansado son voyage de 650 km au port
minéralier tout neuf ou attendait déjà
les premiers transports
[Musique]
avec l'équipement dernier cri
l'automation est reine ainsi de la
montagne de fer au bord de l'Atlantique
fonctionne aujourd'hui une immense
chaîne ininterrompue créée en trois ans
pour approvisionner en minerai les
aciéries de Dunkerque et d'autres en
Belgique dans la rue en Angleterre et en
Italie le minerai de fer est en train de
révolutionner le désert qui fut le
témoin de l'épopée de Mermoz
[Musique]